Adam what more can you tell us
yeah it's believed that at least 16
people have been injured but as you said
seven of them seem to be critically
injured and clearly receiving what is
called emergency treatment now this
explosion happened really in the heart
of Paris for those who know the city uh
if you head south from Notre Dame
Cathedral and head towards the sore Bond
then you're very likely going on this
road uh rusan Jacques and it's just a
little bit further south as you go along
that road in in what is the Latin
quarter where this uh
huge explosion happened and the
devastation that we have seen has been
really very considerable more than 200
firefighters involved in emergency
response now it is worth the same right
at the top that is understood to be a
gas explosion those who run the scene
shortly afterwards reporting
smelling a clear smell of gas in the air
and Hidalgo the mayor of Paris is also
there on the scene but an area that is
very often packed with with visitors
with tourists visiting uh the Latin
quarter what imagines that in this
summer period on a warm day it would
have been uh busy and residents in that
area saying that they simply heard this
huge explosion and they were told very
quickly to evacuate their homes to get
out as rapidly as they could and we have
seen one of these buildings the facade
of it just completely blown off the
front